адже вона кого варіння тут у микаюсь за
за допомогою планшета htc
level sixty nine кузня стартапе на
витрачає дай цьому портик more вчився у
канарі уорф діловому кварталі Лондона
тут свої ідеї в тілі сюжеті molodie
розробкою інноваційних проектів
майстер patterson один з них бізнес ідея
для стартапа ви на claw його дворі
цьому сьогодні підкорених том патерсона
протерти вже 15 осип новачка фірма
спеціалізується на кіборга спати і ви
самі зовсім на що давно малював і в
інтернеті 1000 банківських документів для
внутрішньої розповіді з рідних було
на прокладку confidence in any простому
bespeco банку мотив пішов дому випад куми
воював і у світі g плани будемо замість
банківських філій
відповідно до проблеми і ким ми виявляємо
відкушуємо для таких молодих підприємств
як патерсон канарі уорф
ідеальними sci знайдеш
високотехнологічні діловий квартал
у Європі вже прозвали британську
кремнієву долину мало juice їй Європи та
їду сюди за свої мої dm та на площі
кілька квадратних кілометрів значилося а
місця для травня 2000 інтернет-компаній 140
тисяч противників
розрубують тут новий комп'ютер не туди
ткій три кольори лаку британії вже давно
вже відомо наскільки важливі для
економіка
венчурні інвестиції офіційний Лондон
вдома та стартапам та ряд країни повстання
руки визначав багата у вас і на ваті
їх алюзії цього рахунок кулі вшиті
стартапам жити а головне син зради в
систему у податкова вони я їй спеціальна
на вас Тетяна програма вона про два чаї
значні під від кави та пелігай для
молодих підприємливий так легше
процес прийому працювати
іноземців за крима та громадян краєм
вчений з членами євросоюзу на жаль розширити
компанія батькові на що двору до цього є
пивз основних програміст ендрю hunter
противага будинку сьогодні покрокова
система вакансій одзун а ще місяці кури
коштуватиме від 4 мільйона людей бізнес вже
про буткова
я на спину ще ми добилася від такого
результату крім відури не в
каліфорнії
лондон центр інновацій та технологій то
бізнесу наш веб-сайт і процідити в
росії нідерландах та у денні afrits це
канаді тут лондоні ми зайве людей акі
володіє необхідні мами так само як
навичкам і кут або маркетингу той продаж
ще до кадру ви думаєте wikiz і шукай
крапки кольору
у нас було таких і далекий розумом і для
старту вовків та краси бунт стартапе
відриваючи експорт і здається я в шоколаді
вдасться зменшити темп зростання вона
виключено, що в майбутньому лондонській
кремнію водою і буде ці грамоти в
економіці України на важливу важіль
роль них британський банківський сектор